My Dutch test a couple years ago didn't show screaming high estrogen or bad pathways. I'm
wondering if they are going to help while your Dutch test if you did your Dutch test while
you're on those medications you would see severely depleted estrogen levels. That's the thing. You
could do a Dutch test or a Dutch test is a dried urine hormone test. You could do a Dutch test with
a woman who is ERPR positive and they could have fairly normal to low 16 hydroxy-estero which is
their bad estrogen quote unquote and fairly low for hydroxy-estero which is your other bad estrogen.
And then they're going well what the heck why do I have this cancer then? Okay remember you don't
have breast cancer because of bad estrogens. Bad estrogens are not causing your breast cancer.
Bad estrogens are just limiting apoptosis. So bad estrogens do not cause cancer. So the crazy
insanity of somebody you know you know getting estrogen depleted drugs and then thinking that
they're solving that's the total solve of their breast cancer. That's just not true. You're on
call your spade lead you to believe that but then come back with we need to still do chemotherapy
because chemotherapy can kill cancer depleting all your estrogen is not going to kill cancer.
But it can if you're doing other things like the rife and nutrition it can help get apoptosis
starting. So the tumor can start shrinking because of the other things you're doing not because of
the estrogen depletion. So depleting estrogen is not going to kill the cancer depleting estrogen will
allow the cancer to die because of the other things you're doing. So I hope that answers that question.